all of the warmers I thought you call
that warm your mouth so I am finally
done I never have to take an exam ever
again I am ecstatic about that fact a
mental amount of stuff has happened this
week especially considering how little
effectively has been happening the files
carefully because I didn't study out of
time so you probably notice to this
video is quite long whilst I happened
enforcing a five minute rule for the
rest of time because this is the last
video you can't make me do a punishment
so I'm gonna be this as long as I want
I'm very so happy I'm so so happy right
now
I'm incredibly tired and I'm sort of a
kind of stillness a shock that I don't
have to wake up tomorrow and the physics
I can't even want it but right now if we
can either do a break so on Monday
Tuesday this week I had two papers in
theoretical physics maps very physics
and they were both really devious papers
pretty much everyone who I talked to you
about and thought they didn't go so well
that they were you know tough papers
compared to previous years I got lucky
in the sense that a lot of the stuff
which I revised extensively just didn't
come up and a lot of stuff which I
hadn't rise quite so much camping drives
so um I got unlucky in that sense but
hopefully I'll still be fine to get to
one overall I don't need to get too many
marks in these papers to do so so
fingers crossed I should be good I do
want to say thank you either for all the
wonderful comments they left me on last
week's video when I looked a little bit
crazy and you guys were all wishing good
luck and I really really appreciate that
thank you much like I said in that video
Femina thank you
however I'm guessing you guys don't
really care too much about the actual
exams you're probably more interested in
what happened immediately after them
namely my trashing asserts my friends
that they could do pretty much whatever
they wanted to me in terms of trashing
is within reason on the condition that
they filmed it so I'm going to show you
footage that they took of my trashing
but I need two to three things I need to
say three things first one I absolutely
love my friends we have a fantastic
close-knit social group
but sometimes we can be pricks to
another - right before the exams my
friends found out that my favourite
biscuits with chocolate balban's I mean
of course they are the best biscuit and
so they were dropping off deliveries of
chocolate ovens to keep me going for my
revision sessions a features on 1/3 my
friends seem to think that I never
stopped talking about going to the gym
so um
that explains the protein shakes anyway
I'm going to hand over to their footage
I'm a friend Nathan who's going to be
providing some commentary throughout
after a significant number of detours
around exam scores we're now heading
back towards where Simon with mode is
rumoured that Simon will be released
very easy guys like got off the house
gone that's it revision you don't need
it right he's now ready
we remember Simon out you're in the road
mates get out and that how do you feel
happy happy happy entire how do you feel
because you look ridiculous he's going
home
what's your message Simon what's your
message to the world just to watch me
walk through the message is Martin
Street is bumpy yeah I'm not no we will
cut decry shows Meadows ever very
important very important come Bush aware
that we've arranged
okay all right well this is crazy
ha ha ha ha oh the nose hi it's like a
sprinkler I'm leaf on the wind watch me
soar
save it save the carnations me buy all
of them he's got all of the warmers I
thought you call that one your mouth
Thanks littering it's possible
environment
see ya huh why was the spray yeah well
that's all done yeah that's right Oh No
do you guys probably lost Simon the way
go quick pretty sure that was just a
miscalculation bet you're a prick see
with the state why would you do that the
point a mistake just eating so I'm thank
you guys I guess for that I actually got
off pretty lightly and this is some
footage of some friends of mine actually
other physicists in the envelope here
attract by their friends and they really
got hit really hard in one of the finest
showings of karma I think I've ever seen
my friend Sam who is a physicists and
Peter's got chucked in the river and I
gave him a hand out and then as soon as
he was out on the rack I pushed him back
in again but I didn't push him quite
hard enough because he managed to grab
hold of me and pull me in with him so
just about managed to shut my phone to
the bank make sure to get rude but um I
can't deserve that so after the exams I
was dog-tired and I frankly just went
home and slit but since then I've been
able to make the most of you know life
as a normal person
so actually going to tangs and Oxford
other than the library and the exam
schools the most I think interesting of
this week's activities has been go
to see the writer/director an all-round
king of the Nerds joss whedon at the
Oxford Union he came to do a pre-release
screening of his new film much ado about
nothing
and after that did a Q&A with Amy Acker
and Alexis Denisof the Q&A wasn't noted
just the film though and they were
floating questions about their previous
involvement in angel firefight dr.
Horrible's sing-along blog and just
genuinely he was a incredibly nice
down-to-earth funny guy
I was expecting to be rebuild just not
all like you know a normal person but he
was so nice my favorite part about the
whole experience there was as an as the
talk went on a couple people came in who
were slightly late and they don't want
to disturb everyone who was sat on the
benches so they just stood by the door
but what happened was as um Jose and
Aimee and Alexis left they high-fived
all the students by the door and this
girl unfortunately stopped recording as
this happened after she'd been high five
than the Joss Whedon had left she has
turned to a friend in the row in front
of her and just looked like she died of
happiness and most I couldn't
unfortunately make it to the pre really
screening I have I've heard from
everyone who was there that the film was
actually really really good so if you
like Shakespeare go and see it fact if
you don't like sage Burgos a parameter
like Shakespeare afterwards also this
week I went to formal hall so this was
the last formal hall of term and I
suppose as a consequence to last form of
all my time here at San Peters and a
bunch of our friendship could have all
got together and we all butch spaces and
had nice bottles of wine really nice
food I didn't take footage this term
rogue' so I couldn't bear to it for my
friends got a little bit embarrassed but
had a genuinely really lovely night
fantastic way just to see everybody off
and that kind of has actually been the
feel of the whole week really um you've
been with these people for three year in
some cases for years and it hasn't it
didn't hit me really that I had to say
goodbye to them until the day after my
exam when a new car go oh my god I have
to leave because I think when you're
doing exams you're thinking I've only
got you know two days left of my degree
or two days left
don't have to do physics again for the
summer you don't tend to think I've got
a week left until I don't see my friends
again so it's sad but this week is a
chance to without anywhere without
anybody having any work just be able to
enjoy spending time of your friends in
one of the most beautiful cities in the
world which you know isn't bad
unfortunately weather hasn't been so
great but hopefully next week because
I'm have one more week
we'll be going punting and just reading
books in the sunshine and going out and
I'm looking forward to making the most
of the time I have it's kind of maybe
almost philosophical I guess like it's
made me think yeah only so much time
make the most of it with the people that
you have I make sure you tell people how
much they mean to you before you don't
get the chance to and that very much
applies to you guys I mean I know that I
said thank you for all the support
you've given me over the past year but
this is ultimately now drawing to the
conclusion of project which is taken up
a year and hundreds of hours of effort
from my part and frankly from your part
for actually sitting through the videos
and I want to say again that you guys
have been really important to me this
year uploading my videos has sometimes
been a bit of it sure especially when
I've been very tired a husband evidenced
and some of those visit some videos this
year but be able to relay the experience
of being student here and feeling
responsibility to do that has been a
fantastic experiment a fantastic
experience for me and I hope that you
guys have found it informative and at
times entertaining and whilst yes this
is the end of the oxblood project from
my channel this kind of work is going to
be continuing next year and that's
something which I'm currently in talk to
the university about doing so this is it
from me making vlogs but I'm going to
continue making videos and other octave
students are going to continue making
vlogs I'm going to actually upload the
whole video probably in the next couple
of weeks detailing the future of this
channel but rest assured you haven't
seen the last of me
I've always been terrible at saying
goodbye I kind of person instead of
saying goodbye to sort of waves and then
awkwardly shuffles out of room you can't
really do that the internet perhaps I
can only say this I've really enjoyed
the time that we've had
and I can only hope that you have as
well I'll see you see